In this example, we're looking at the spread of Syrian refugees to
neighboring countries during the Syrian uprising in 2011.
There isn't much we can do here other than press play and
watch the story unfold before our eyes.
So let's press.
We can scrub through time on the bottom here, and mouse over the line plots to
get more exact numbers, but largely, the author has predetermined how we
view this data set, as a particular narrative that is to be conveyed.
Remembering back to our spectrum,
we see here this is an appropriate use of a author-driven visualization.
The author is trying to impose a strict ordering, the ordering being time,
and wants us to see how the refugees have
spread out between the years of 2012 and 2014.
Let's look at a second example.
In this example from the New York Times, we're looking at the Facebook IPO and
how it compares with other IPOs in the last 30 years.
We saw this in lesson one when talking about double encodings.
But now, let's take a look at its narrative structure.
Like the last example, a strict ordering is imposed as we're
walked through a specific narrative with the above text.
We see here that there are five stages that we're supposed to click through.
As we move through the stages, we see the data stretch and
transform, allowing us to dig deeper into each data point.
Annotations also appear,
drawing our attention to specific data points of interest.